[Music]
[Music]
what is up everybody how's it going
happy Thursday or you know afraid
[Music]
whichever you prefer how's it go and
hope everyone is doing well today is
April 30th which means there's bugs and
fish going out of season won't be back
for a while so today we're gonna try to
take advantage of the moments and get
everything we're missing so far so I
hope you guys are having a good day I
hope you're ready for some more animal
crossing I honestly can't get enough of
this game but you know I hope you guys
are in that same boat with me there so
yeah how's it going welcome welcome I am
at the airport right now because I do
have a another Island I'm working on
there's some cool fun and games and that
one is on the southern hemisphere we do
have an article that I'm about to link
right now actually that lists out
everything that's leaving after today so
the goal is to try to catch everything I
don't have on that list yeah what's good
Brandon welcome back how's it going
alright boom check out that article if
you want to know what's leaving
I have northern hemisphere island right
now so in terms of fish the blue marlin
the dab in the tuna are all going on a
season and then the tarantulas also
going out of season um I think I might
have all four of those because those are
the only ones leaving let's check it out
also this morning guys I finally caught
the dinosaur fish this morning like it's
probably still where is it where is it
did I accidentally scroll over it and
lose a little notification oh there it
is
the last one on the list I finally got
in this morning
cuz it's been raining on my island all
day and the last few times said it
rained on my Island I had people over
and they caught one night in catch one
so I finally got him he's mine
and he is in the museum I instantly ran
to the museum and put in there okay so
blue marlin check tuna check and I
definitely have the dab there is okay
and I don't need all three of those and
then III of cherish life I've been sure
and Sheila huntin before there is okay
so when I hop over to this other Island
which is a southern hemisphere island
I'm gonna need an angelfish let's see I
have the angelfish I feel like I do this
is it right yeah I got the inefficient I
made a better betta better I don't think
I have one of those so I'm gonna be
looking for one of those
I have catfish right there I have the
old rainbow fish I don't think I have
the rainbow fish so viewing for a
rainbow fish I have the ribbon eel I
don't have a snapping turtle but that's
9 p.m. to 4 a.m. so I don't think I'm
gonna be able to get him and I had the
tilapia so I really only have a few more
fish wise but the bugs I'm gonna need
also they're scorpions on southern
hemisphere I'm not gonna be able to get
that that's in the evening time I might
have to dine a dragonfly
let's see oh I have three of them I've
read Darner and banded so I'm good on
dragonflies idly
bug have man facing bug mantis okay I
have a mantis
I might have all of those bugs already
oh oh my goodness okay so we're going
fishing we're going fishing because I
think I think I have everything else
except for the Scorpion which is
unfortunate because that's not gonna be
in my timeframe to get on the stream but
it's all good yeah it's all in that link
on the game's island will not be open it
won't because it's still a work in
progress right now actually so yeah
[Music]
right now all right so I'm having is why
I'm against by Island open I'm gonna hop
over there world
[Music]
what is up one known I don't know how's
it going welcome welcome but you know I
will preview a little bit of this island
even though it's under construction and
it's not gonna be open any time super
soon but soon and eventually but it's
definitely made to have fun with you
guys and do some cool games and I'm
working on a really awesome runway so
yeah let's go the mic might be picking
it up alright what is animal grazi
Animal Crossing is is basically a way of
life at this point you know Joseph
what's good normal what's good how's it
goin welcome
Alex hello oh I see the L in the
underscore and the one is supposed to be
a you got [ __ ] so you guys get an
exclusive sneak peek right now at my
work in progress
fun in games GameSpot Islands yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I mean it's super super super still
under construction and I do need to kind
of like a beta test a few things out to
see if they even aware how I'm imagining
them but the main thing yo [ __ ] he
looks good but the main thing today is
just take advantage of this the southern
hemisphere right now to get all of the
stuff moving today April 30th tomorrow
marks a new season
which is excess
[Music]
I've been trying super hard though
skip this island up and poppin more
efficient today we're fishing how you
guys doing by the way
we're almost to Friday guys this is the
waiting room so that when I do start the
fun and games I'm gonna put a bush here
so people can't walk through until we're
ready to have them but yeah okay so I
want to fish a lot cuz there's things I
need to catch I might have an extra
fishing rod in my pocket already though
I don't know how I juggle of my own
island and this island yeah me neither
actually
okay I'm gonna get another fishing rod I
mean II do it for the love for the love
of game and game spots yes we probably
do have a new upload because we be
posting every single day live streaming
every single day ooh I live I love these
screams but this thing's like a hundred
and thirty thousand yeah I have a
different I have another one that has a
different pattern in my bathroom all
right so I got myself an extra oh really
I'm about to buy that cool
oh I forgot I am a transform this used
to be my main office it's why I forgot
okay I need that I need wait where is it
bypasses how I did I'm buying
dragon suits maybe my crown will attract
Tara will attract the fish sleeve it on
all right let me pull out this list
again
we're gonna keep track what I'm looking
for
all right need a betta fish that's the
first one we're looking for and that is
in the river all right let's go let's do
this
[Music]
t rivers here you'll notice these are
some starting points for the summaries
that goes over to the left I'm not going
to show you guys what's over there yet
[Music]
all right we're looking for some little
fishies in the river well ok Cairo in
the chat is looking for some bathroom
furniture furniture
this guy's in a weird angle here and he
is swimming pretty fast if we get a bead
on the first go
that would be funny I also think I need
a goldfish oh yeah which is also very
cute I used to have like a big fish
thing when I was growing up and we just
have a bunch of those in there which is
super cute I don't want to look too far
over there
the prize of that race over there uh
yeah this is the million dollar crown
and then my friends actually gifted me
the 1.2 million dollar but don't call it
so I just hang it up on the wall looks
better on the wall than it does on my
head
[Music]
oh how are you liking she to the Streets
of Rage Brandon I have so much fun
playing that yesterday actually it made
me want to play fighting in a really bad
I think it was because you know just
playing on arcade six ask oh my gosh
this fish it's gonna be like a bogey oh
I have cards left irony but that is one
of the fish leaving
[Music]
this is another racetrack
[Music]
I still need a flavour between the sea
bass and the black I felt like those are
the two fish I catch the lips mines
right next year take a little peak to
the left
what's good will you I'm doing well how
are you how's it going for you oh no /
if real
[Music]
[Music]
yeah aha
she looks hot as I am River okay yeah
[Music]
rainbow fish also in the river so the
things I need that I can get right now
are all in their eyes on the river 100%
or not
[Music]
oh heck yeah please for all you guys if
you have not earned flavor all play for
all going on this summer we're gonna be
doing a lot of really cool stuff talking
about games playing the
hanging out together but separately tape
with Laurie Beals but we do have some
more information on that up on the
website we also talked about it a bit on
one of the episodes this week of safety
that chastity hosted and if you guys
haven't seen savestate it's our brand
new daily news show and myself
Luci chastity and Curt we take turns
with the hosting duties on that show so
[Music]
[Music]
all right we need up beta and
rainbowfish I can't get the scorpion yet
but I'm hoping I can find these two
fairly early okay
god she's so pretty doing boobs like she
is really because it was like a frilly
fish but so cute alright so we got that
one and the rainbow fish alright now
just see rainbow fish
I know how babe is no maybe I should
check my rainbow it would probably look
colorful like a rainbow right I don't
think I have a rainbow
[Music]
now chance to see it
[Music]
Saamy last weekend Tetris 99e I love
that game although I've gotten I've
gotten a bit rusty
no these chairs that I wonder how big
the rainbow like hiding in the shoes
okay I bought another one yeah let's get
punished here welcome back hey if you
have any questions please feel free
that's what we're here for
[Music]
okay rainbow fish rainbow fish or I can
be a cheater and then after I find the
rainbow fish I can suck this line later
we can't believe I did spend a couple of
days before this island existed farming
on my friends trying to get shirts like
a potential rainbow fish sighs
potentially
[Music]
there's a nook mile sing where you have
to hit a rock eight times and we did but
you didn't get the reward I'm not sure
because usually after you do it it will
automatically trigger B is in one I did
notice recently though is that sometimes
there's a few seconds delayed but I've
noticed a delay any larger than just a
second I always get chakra and I see a
pink shadow in the river but then it's
like a boot just us
um yeah the name of the island this
island is actually really
earth
[Music]
yeah because there's still some other
southern hemisphere fish I haven't
caught that aren't seasonal that aren't
labeled today I'm just trying to
prioritize the the rainbow fish
[Music]
[Music]
alright I'll just know what I find oh my
gosh good I don't have the code right
now but I did make a game slot shirt
[Music]
no fatigue well man the river is really
weird with the ingles aha she thought of
it yeah there's not many other places to
look at this little visit
[Music]
[Music]
we guess I'm getting nervous out of the
clock on this Ireland is actually 3050
which means I have 10 minutes left
applying this rainbow business
oh hi rainbow fish you come to save my
life mr. pretty those four islands are
very pretty dude everyone's island is
great I always feel bad when like I show
off my Island somebody and they're like
oh my gosh my Island sucks I'm like no
it does it eventually this fish with you
[Music]
like all the shadows that aren't the
tiny ones quick masses come on it's
right there right next to you yo you
fish they're rude sometimes they're rude
well he's got to see this one
I love any of your neighborhood right
there yeah oh all that work for the bass
[Music]
I've just been letting my flowers run
rampant on this island I've been working
on other stuff
[Music]
tiger beetle is also leaving today
catch one yes
[Music]
Hey Oh I've gotten 66 cool um still need
that rainbow fish though speaking sure
again
because I goofed at the time all weird
on this island are anybody got an island
that woman can visit hey guys built
three two of your island codes here
y'all can meet up with each other so far
every time we've done an animal crossing
stream we've been getting some island
group zones so don't be shy
you're gonna beat a switch
throw that even mean we got the light
switch light okay I might go back in the
donut might go back to my island and
donate my fish soon come back and keep
trying for this rainbow fish touch
you're doing way out there out onto the
ocean
[Music]
Oh two yellows
I have not been paying attention to all
the flower guys because I couldn't focus
on decorating stuff
random movement
we'd be left ton of awesome flower guys
up right now if you guys into that
you're gonna get all the chance colors I
think most mostly my rare colors either
came from a mystery Island or I got
lucky
so happiness is certain colors together
and got the other colors on this island
whenever red sums I kind of just put
this here so I can run straight and she
was island instead of having to climb
over everything about my main island
it's super hard to get to and I'm not
doing that
I mean rainbow fish have I still been
playing valoran and again of balance I
always say the name that game I love
then actually I'm having a lot of fun
with that game I'm getting better slowly
but surely but it can still be crushing
at times just cuz you know that system
is not very forgiving and if you're new
to something like that just I don't know
for me it takes me a long time to get
good at games so I spent a long time
being really bad at games before I get
to a point where I'm still good at it
but I am doing better so that's been fun
am i running out of space yet two more I
have two more slots left in my pockets
before I'm gonna go donate and sell and
try again
[Music]
also please see me one of the top
overwatch players quit to be pro dollars
I mean I don't doubt it
I've been seeing a split also I think he
just won something and you know he's you
the apex got some pretty cool I mean the
game is definitely gonna shake shake up
the scene
as a fighting game player sometimes you
just know
now when I museum comes out things are
gonna change
it's Animal Crossing sort of like
minecraft in a way you know you build I
mean nothing really kills you
tarantulas and scorpions and wasps can
sting you bite you all right I'm gonna
head back to my island real quick on the
donate and sell these new additions I'll
come back and try again I mean also
trying to go to night food and oh this
is my Heather
and try to get those those nighttimes um
bugs and fish too so you guys can see
them yeah I'm actually excited to donate
these fish because they're so pretty
I might quote the betta fish in my house
or something
Brandon Bivens that's good
how's it going welcome back to be honest
that I have not stopped thinking about
shoots of rage for since I played
yesterday it was so fun and cherry is
super cool
[Music]
I will all get up for the rain
[Music]
and kicks is on my yellow rose is
growing back right there again I'm like
told that yellow rose up that's fine a
lot all righty
yo blathers we got some cool stuff and
I'm gonna make some good money
I like interjecting into their
conversation because they're always
talking about crazy stuff you glasses
wake up room we've got some good news
make a brain a shoe right check it and I
got one of these I need to catch a bald
fish I've caught him before but that was
before I had the museum and it was still
under construction and they sold it like
an idiot 25 bucks for Streets of Rage 4
is a good price can't complain yeah for
real because it's really fun
Thank You fathers we're also gonna go
check because yeah I want to see it I
know where the data is I went to my
friend's aquarium who almost has every
single fish and it looks so good
so I'm pretty sure this is gonna be in
the front tank right here so gorgeous I
love it and the Guppies looks so pretty
what's good Tasha she is chillin and she
calms it off yes oh man I love it I
think between this tank and the shark
tank it's probably two of my favorite
yay and I just caught dinosaur fish
today we're gonna go say hi to him even
though I said hi to him already we gotta
do it and then we're gonna head back to
gamespot Island try to get that
angelfish and yeah show off my dog I'm
proud it's a keeper thing long time get
it oh my gosh my shoes they're so long
he's right there so cool that part were
a fish so I really feel like all right
and go sell these goods to Tommy Tim and
then we back on the grind I really I
haven't got a snapping turtle either but
I wanna catch multiple snapping turtle
that's because you can actually place
them outside and they look like pets
so yeah go man I saw some of it I saw
some fanart today
that was dinosaur villagers and I was
like they're super cute but it would be
so morbid
there's like display I got forces of
your relatives display but they're
really cute the art was really good but
I see why they don't I see my also
learned a really cool only 9000 I felt
like I had a lot of cool fish right
there but I guess that's fine so really
good I don't even know if I'm put in my
house but it's something I don't have
yet
trying to expand my catalog
all right we must dump these few items
in my storage and then we're heading
back to GameSpot to get that angelfish
that angelfish is the last thing I need
and then after that I have some
nighttime fish like the snapping turtle
and do I replace my mean I have an emo
in my room wow I love it okay
it matches the colors all right let's go
hello team how's it goin
am I gonna be doing it there I'll in
heck this is already so much and my
second island like the gamespot island
it's still it's flying it's offering you
guys it's actually oh yeah I kinda want
to put on my oh snap looks like Juan is
gonna open up his Island if you guys are
looking for an I want to visit today
please make friends you guys that's the
coolest thing about this game right you
know I don't play these games now drop
that dodo code so uh other people tuning
in can visit your Island on screen feel
free oh yeah gotta fly I've been located
thinking about creating an office space
on gamespot Island and every day taking
my character and going to the island and
sitting her there so it feels like I'm
going into the office
that was benighted he would come to the
island but you don't have a switch oh
yeah yeah that's pretty important and
they've been super hard to get I've been
hearing which is unfortunate I kind of
wanted my mom to get this so she could
play with me
[Music]
alright angels I mean rainbowfish time
I do enjoy
I do enjoy the music in this game a lot
oh let's get this rainbow fish I did a
little looking and it looks like it's a
tiny shadow so hopefully we can opt out
quick and then we'll jump over whoa
first light first light someone was
hungry and that would've been great move
in first go see fish whisperer
[Music]
so far so far what a thorough
[Music]
my water is almost mystical
[Music]
let's give them expense we love you too
that's why we all know the orchid is
scared of the light that's why we're
here every day streaming for you did Ben
and John Luke decide what they're gonna
play for community Friday's show and
play I know they've had a few games
they've been wanting to do but we also
like to stay on what's going down but
they'll be here no worries and it's not
then I'll be here so it's all good we
got you guys covered I'm not sure when I
used to work in a bakery and bakery in
New York and all the kids cakes for a
while they're all we'll all of them they
wanted peppa pig and it's always
interesting to see what's trending in
terms of kids shows and stuff like that
because
I still think the most popular cakes
we've ever like we had ever done we're
frozen bird like you know Disney's
frozen Elsa and in all them
up they're actually right next to like
Sesame Street characters really really
interesting to see the chance oh I
forgot I'm not other avatar I was like
one it's like a weird twin story I'm
doing this with no feet
[Music]
yeah it's Thursday you know we're
getting to another week
also another use of quarantine it's
actually been weird how time is going so
fast weeks are just going by so fast
really crazy you would think since
you're stuck at home you can't go
anywhere I kind of feel like it's
dragging my way I feel quite the
opposite
don't know if it's just because I'm
getting older or you know space into a
more worthy she wants everything Sonic
oh my gosh that means he must have loved
the sonic movie
honestly I loved the sonic movie too I'm
also very easily impressed so take that
very well I thought it was great
it made me laugh on more than one
occasion and that's enough for me
[Music]
come on rainbow fish and media
[Music]
and this making sure what I'm pretty
sure he's like right here that he'll
he'll live like right here
shadows tiny enough but it's tiny shadow
and let the river take the Lord's and
him my little caution sign because this
area is not completed yet honestly my
favorite part of the island right now we
haven't even walked anywhere near it
at all James White
the gamespot island is not open yet it's
still under construction but soon I'll
make sure that I not only post when it's
open in the game spot this morning but
I'll also post on Twitter purple
shimmery what is good all of its funny
how's it going hallo is your childhood a
big scene big save halo 2 is one of my
most favorite games of all time coming
in I don't know why when I think
childhood I think like child child that
was pretty much like a teenager
but hey yeah those are the golden years
old
[Music]
[Music]
Oh already you can't wait for price to
ff7 remake I mean the original is really
long so with how they've expanded and
you know how they details that whole
world over again I'm surprised they're
releasing it in parts but I mean I've
heard nothing but great things about it
when I played the demo was really really
fun my backlog of beans has just been so
long I haven't had a chance to actually
buy the full version yet and play it but
it's 100% on the list and maybe I mean I
know it's probably not but as someone
who loves Kingdom Hearts and didn't beat
the first Final Fantasy but played a bit
of it recently I think it's really cool
and they have different modes for
different people which is also cool
because it's drastically different in my
opinion in terms the employees from the
original some people are picked and
there is
throw all that extra effort do the other
stuff but come on even though you're not
the shadows I try it down here here we
go
oh no will we be live-streaming Last of
Us part 2 when it comes out absolutely
I'm actually super excited I was really
bummed when the date heck out and push
back but I mean you know with good
reason
but onyx I'm exact because the first was
very I don't know what the right organ
would be like I don't know
I still think about it sometimes just
like oh man asleep so messed up I hope
we never ever have
[Music]
apocalypse style thing light back one I
would not survive and to just be so wild
who does that
Macross what's good welcome
happy Thursday
I still living out in this rainbow fish
come on rainbow fish I need you gotta
get all these big old fish out the way
come on oh my gosh I was kind of hoping
it would be like a tire or something
alright let's go get another fishing rod
oh man I got a feeling I'm not gonna
find this fish it's gonna be that one
fish as always can't get I tried to get
the dinosaur fish a lot a lot of times
every time it rained I finally got it
today but that's what's making me feel
like I'm a gag is slate from always seen
so far with Ellie she's a badass super
badass so I'm interested to see that
evolution
Oh Chris character great rainbow fish
what playing games in my heart oh I
don't mean to do that I was frightened
I ran inviting those signs for it to
annoy me I think that's pretty much the
beauty though of there being crossover
in like me because in games people
didn't even know that existed they get
to get introduced to it get to grow the
community
I like crossover is great
[Music]
nope
what do you want waluigi in smash i mean
i don't really play smash so the
characters i wouldn't want to see in
smash would never admit it but it would
be to see them in a game like that like
Dube died or something I think you have
been wanting big guys for a while
actually
I mean now that I have my own switch if
I could try out smash
[Music]
[Music]
you want waluigi branding
[Music]
I still need to finish do it's just
nightmare emotes been kicking my ass I
will get back to it just like when I
first played it on nightmare like I have
gotten more comfortable and learned it
and then I took a long break and then I
was back oh my god I forgot how to do
everything and I was you know further
along in the story where I difficult
nightmare load is no joke it's fun
though it's a massive challenge but and
I've been playing on controller which is
also really sad anymore Valerie I should
try it on PC since I've finally gotten
used to mouth something a little bit
more because I there's some things that
are just so hard to pull off seamlessly
on a controller Ali plays games of
getting new friends tomorrow oh well
congratulations that's awesome I was
gonna catch that like at mantis but I'm
on the hunt for this rainbow fish yes
and were no fishy I'm trying to get all
the fish because there's fish and bugs
leaving today
you know after April they won't be back
for a while because of seasonal changes
so I'm trying to get them all I have
rainbow fish well I have a snapping
turtle lab this is southern hemisphere
by the way so I have rainbow fish left
snapping turtle left in a square pan
three more one final thing and in case
you guys didn't see the link earlier I'm
gonna post them in here right now but we
do have this guide along with other
guides on our website right now related
to fishing seasonal items tips designs
all that all that jazz so here's a link
I just put the link in the description
or in the chat whoa - too many YouTube
voiceovers yeah in case you want to see
if there's anything you're missing and
in case you didn't know it's a blessing
right now I'm looking for a small shadow
tiny shadows in the river pray this
rainbow fish need to get this game I
agree I feel like everyone
[Music]
this is like the main river oh he had to
swim forward a little bit didn't there
we go big boy is that a wonderful the
sturgeon unfortunate I'm wearing the
mask as it goes with my outfit looks
like a cool ninja and it goes with my
umbrella also yeah ever since I got the
umbrella I've been waiting for it to
rain and it finally rained on my back
every yes it is you actually relax
[Music]
all this fishing is making you hungry
what's your favorite fish to eat mine is
probably a tie between like a really
good fried catfish like actually I think
that maybe my ask my favorite something
[Music]
to last the various years
I don't need you
go away bring me the tiny shadows man
someone's heart was going off how did I
get a star one I got it when I talked to
Celeste she gave me the recipe but this
star one I have right now actually
Brandon's gifted it to me and so but
usually all the star one recipes or all
the wand recipes I got the star walk I
did get a star one recipe from Celeste
on the night of a meteor shower and then
there's like the fish one and egg
bamboo or tons of hummus
I think there was even like a cherry
blossoms in make you guys did the cherry
blossom stuff this game is not free I
think it's like 60 bucks like the price
of it full whole new release game where
is the rainbow fish that is money
question to Eduardo yeah pocket camp and
if you you know get [ __ ] camp first
and then later get Animal Crossing you
can actually get you can unlock oh I
can't view the special goods from my
okay well if you go to the next terminal
you get some special hockey camp items
by linking your accounts there's like a
really awesome campsite signs that I
absolutely need it for making I'll try
to get there's really cute fortune
cookie stands
I don't think yes that is very nice
compliments I don't like I struggle
listening to my own voice and you know
there's also that thing where you sound
different than your own then you do it
really though the struggles I think this
shadow is too big to be the rainbows
finish Jordan
so Salah we got another big Celeste is
blathers his sister she shows up not
every meteor shower but most of the time
bristle she'll show up on your island at
night
I think after like 9 p.m. or something
putting bad we do have a guide on all
the characters I can see our line up on
the website so check that out
but she shows up at night some usually
on the meteor shower at night she walks
around she's like a red and pink and
light pole she's super cute probably one
of my favorite characters that visits
your Island
Kix being number one and yeah she just
comes here Island randomly there's
nothing you can really do to trigger
come on rainbow fish where are you at
man it's it's so sad because we got all
the other fish like super fast like not
showing up all of my racetracks are
currently a work in progress
[Music]
but I'm hoping that they actually work
[Music]
[Music]
where is this fish
I need it you know my game I'm actually
super excited about it's gonna sound so
silly but the name fun Bob remaster I am
super excited for that remember playing
the old one I think I know I've heard of
you the old spongebob PC game when I was
younger honor like super old computer
oh my pockets are full already
I'm just gonna sell these here I didn't
get all these by the way the first part
of the fun and games
you selfish
um you can buy pocket upgrades from next
terminal in case your guys wondering
about that musashi so so cute video and
gation this game is super cute I love it
alright by all my fishies so I can make
back my money from that tub I bought
earlier I kind of really like the videos
when I give one to all of my village now
like the pike is worth of one generally
did not get that much it's fine oh man
it's already really come on Nanna help
me Nanna help me find the fish yes
yeah got it let's go okay finally see
the rainbow fish was just jealous they
wanted all this space all right now let
me check to make sure yeah ooh yeah ooh
and I guessed the right spot there it is
the rainbow fish we've caught it right
on top
cool all right so should I try to spend
the last twenty minutes getting the
snapping turtle and the Scorpion because
those are the last two seasonal ones I
mean we're gonna do it I think I I think
I can so let's go donate this yeah that
boy finally got donate this we're gonna
come back it's magically gonna be
nighttime on James Island and then we're
gonna try for the snapping turtle and
the scorpion those are the last two last
to see some of the believes that we need
before it's too late today if I can get
all of these within the streamside limit
oh it actually be really clutch yo boy
[Music]
it's variants scary like I accidentally
like got stung by one when I was
creating the island
yeah the switches man I was talking
about it earlier
[Music]
I got super lucky I got mine literally
like three days after branti and started
think it was in the mail the package had
even got to the ladies too so luckily I
did you know I was able to get it in
time thanks to a friend who I was
actually helping me out and finding it
um but yeah super lucky I'm glad though
would have been great if it didn't make
it in a way to go on or I got refunded
or something which would be my luck the
first time I tried to buy the animal
crossing switch which is the one that I
had my first order got cancelled this is
rough you'll bloody blabs let's keep
this beautiful city right here blob is
right it is Gladys
we worked super hard to get that yes
tell me about my magnificent catch known
her to metallic colors and beautiful
things different species each a unique
and pleasing color exciting hues and
under baked brownie flowers so I got to
do this to yourself he's so sad look you
lose face and there you have it
fascinating stuff I don't know if this
one's gonna be in the little tank or it
probably will be we're gonna go back
it's night time on gamespot Island now
we're gonna get the snapping turtle and
the scraper the last two seasoned items
that I need both north and
self I put the link in the chat earlier
or you could see the full list of all
the fish and bugs leaving uncle Rex
isn't here now it's a rainbow fish in
here oh it is it's right there in the
corner
he looks okay I wasn't he looks lonely
but there there's two there's two
awesome your ex Rex like wow this is
selling everybody about the betta fish
nice
all right back
it's a game spawn island
[Music]
let's go because up in the escape these
always make me feel like there's weeds
on the ground
I always run over to like I'm gonna lie
another fishing rod some very low
because you guys cute one of my starts
made with the duck yell need another
[Music]
mechanism that insulite for sure for
sure see you scorpion or hopefully it
doesn't sneak up on me on my main island
the one I'm on right now like there's so
much stuff on my island that now I can't
see when there's a tarantula running
after me they just pop up and I have to
try to like and maneuver it don't kids
done yet I know I got stung it's fine
[Music]
[Music]
alright we gotta try and get the turtle
the turtle
[Music]
but with Dodos do what would Dodos do I
mean the whole joke is that dodo birds
can't fly they're running headed you
know an airline I don't know if you guys
heard that Hawk outside I swear the road
rage and the traffic outside my house is
weird we're all supposed to be like on
Korean team there's so much going out
there here's a war over Halo
I don't know I can't breathe without
[Music]
okay it's scorpion and snapping turtle
time which one will I run into you first
I would like 10 minutes to do it
[Music]
[Music]
by Outland fruits first cast
[Music]
pretty big shadow I think this is it
more than 10 usually when you get
something like that's a large shadow and
kind of rare
[Music]
perfect throw I did finally get the cast
master achievement maxed out which i
think is like a hundred catches in a row
without losing a fish
[Music]
huh
I remember when the fishing tournament
was going on every time it would take a
fish like five nipples to actually buy
it more MORE I'm good so like all the
fish gonna keep our eyes peeled for
maybe too many flowers
[Music]
I'm not sure what the requirements are
um yes so zcp its April 30th and on May
1st the seasons are changing so there's
a list of you know there's certain fish
and bugs that are going out of season
after today so today is actually your
last chance to get them so here here's
the article that we have up on the
website right now this has a list of
everything if you don't get them today
you have to wait until they're back in
season for example like I don't know if
each one of the fish on this list are
coming back at the same time but the
tarantulas aren't coming back until
November so if you want to do some trash
on the farming it's probably be in your
best interest to do it now you know do
you think it looks like me I tried to
make it look like new but there's not
that many options I wasn't paying
attention it's okay I tried my best but
there's like 10 options so but the glass
is that everything I tried
[Music]
I would assume the snapping turtles
shadow sizes a larger one but I could be
wrong
and catching all the DS give me all this
oh snap this might be the one
[Music]
all right you know what
don't turn your back yeah
okay oh I feel like I'm joking it all
right we thought I need to catch another
one but yeah he definitely that doesn't
look like a chunky old shadow so could
this possibly be it all right all that's
left our sketch now is the sport beer
yes
all right cool I got one from my house
and one for the museum money all right
it's time where can we find a string
like it's not I can show you guys my
work in progress
up here
oh snap CJ's actually here was good i
should have been selling all my fish to
CJ
hold up oh man oh wait this is in my eye
[Music]
so work in progress but sanshin chill i
work super hard on this but this is
where we're going to be having some
interstellar fashion shows with everyone
I have all the lights I just need to
place them just pop them today so that's
gonna see a nice little sneak peek
we've never seen a blue marlin it's a
bit big it's big
remember going bigger than the two
minutes in that ballpark hmm I wonder
what this kitty even though I'm done
fishing every time I see a large shadow
I can't help myself that's what I get
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna fish anymore
I'm embarrassed that was probably a full
of fish but we'll never know because
I've loved it never in my life would I
do saying this
come here scorpions on there in the
middle of my racetrack
[Music]
oh no girl
so far it's not supposed to be efficient
in here because it's my racetrack that's
the one or construction but he's here so
we might as well scrape you let me not
get the strife des for a minute for a
minute
I catch Smurfs in that's okay you guys
still having to the end of the day to
catch to catch all of these seasonal
fish on the list
[Music]
don't worry I just have only a few
minutes less extreme to catch this Ruby
this last one run too fast and like
startled one after me but you want to
try to look quickly every branch I see
and like status
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
monster games don't be shy most alight
you have too much random stuff around
for it's a spot even when I've been
working on this island I haven't seen a
spoken--
[Music]
well I did I fell one I got some bad but
since then I don't think you would be on
the baby
[Music]
there's got Ono my console battery's low
on good spot island whoa this stream is
should be careful to lobby to shut down
and then I don't get my girl all right
listen I think to morning
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
River romance I don't think I'm gonna
find it before the end of stream but
that's the last one actually did some
good work my favorite you know pretty
bad like everything but I would probably
have to say maybe like cheese you know
she's so good with everything can make a
bunch of stuff like I could say he isn't
seeing up like 20 things looks to you
that I freaking love
[Music]
I don't know that's tough question cool
stream oh thank you
cool viewers how about that thank you
guys so much for hanging out by the way
this is going to close out the stream
[Music]
all right here don't see it fills valve
is all good because we got everything
else seasonal in the bag I guess I'll
just have to wait and Berthier back to
get them but thank you guys so much for
tuning in please don't forget that every
single weekday at 2:00 p.m. Pacific time
we are alive right here and we also have
UK team streaming live every Tuesday and
Thursday as well and we also have
content going up on gamespot comm and on
our youtube every single day so make
sure you're keeping an eye out for that
- really appreciate it yeah at least I
got the turtles fur girl I was very
excited about that yeah thank you guys
so much
tune in tomorrow and tomorrow's
community Fridays or Ben and John Lee
will be playing games with you guys I'm
not sure what's on the docket just yet
but be here it's gonna be fun
have a good one and we'll see ya next
time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]